ja und heute morgen um 6 uhr hieß es
zugriff nach bild-informationen führte
die bundespolizei razzien in berlin und
essen durch dabei soll auch der
drahtzieher eines international
operierenden preis passfehler netzwerkes
in seiner berliner wohnung festgenommen
worden sein
der vorwurf der mann ließ über einen
fälscher ring in athen verfälsche
dokumente herstellen und dann nach
deutschland liefern mehr dazu weiß mein
kollege max kiewel mir jetzt auch
zugeschaltet max was genau können wir
bereits über den mutmaßlichen kopf
dieser bande sagen ja er heisst keine
idee ist 2013 nach berlin gekommen und
muss dann irgendwann in den jahren
danach kontakte aufgebaut haben nach
athen zu einem fälscher netzwerk du hast
es gerade gesagt und hat dann von dort
dokumente bezogen und die verkauft
einerseits an menschen in deutschland
die hier illegal leben und ihren ihren
status in deutschland scheint
legalisieren möchten und auf der anderen
seite aber auch an migranten die noch im
ausland sind und mit diesen dokumenten
in die eu einreisen wollten
heute gab es ausserdem dann auch eine
razzia in griechenland in athen
was es dort passiert genau das haben wir
in den letzten stunden noch einmal
bestätigt bekommen also mehrere
wohnungen sind in athen gestürmt worden
das soll mehr oder weniger zeitgleich zu
den maßnahmen in berlin stattgefunden
haben das macht ja auch sinn wenn dort
sozusagen die eigentliche feltscher
netzwerke das eigentliche feltscher büro
die die werkstatt ist die ist gestürmt
worden wir wissen dass ein syrer
festgenommen worden ist und was auch
interessant ist es ist ein man kann sich
das vorstellen wie bei uns dann später
gestürmt worden ein kleiner kiosk der
eigentlich cola bier verkauft und wo man
aber auch pakete und post aufgeben kann
und genau aus diesem kiosk sollen eben
die lieferungen nach deutschland
gegangen sein dass so eine art schein
kiosk eigentlich gewesen sein
wie gut können denn behörden hier in
deutschland noch woanders die dokumente
unterscheiden zu echten wie wie gut
waren diese fälschungen gibt es da schon
einen einstand zu
die fälschung sollen generell sehr gut
gewesen sein
dazu muss man auch wissen die meldeämter
in deutschland in den großen metropolen
in berlin hamburg frankfurt die sind mit
modernsten geräten ausgestattet dort
sind mitarbeiter geschult worden auf
kleine ungenauigkeiten in den dokumenten
zu achten aber gerade in der provinz in
kleinen meldebehörden muss vielleicht
nur 23 mitarbeiter arbeiten dort gibt es
diese maschinen nicht was eben ermittler
in den letzten jahren festgestellt haben
am wenn leute mit illegalen dokumenten
kommen dann gehen sie vor allem in die
provinz dann probieren sie das
auszunutzen dass in den wäldern und
bürgerämtern dort eben die technische
ausstattung und die bildung noch nicht
so groß ist wie in den großen metropolen